hi everyone
uh welcome to a conversation with dr
anthony fauci
i'm sad omar and the director of the
yale institute for
global health and i'm delighted to
welcome everyone to this first event for
the yale
global health conversation series um a
venue for our community to learn from
and and connect with innovative leaders
in global health
um and so in addition to uh
ygh uh we are indebted to uh
george herbert walker junior lecture in
international studies
um at the macmillan center um and
um i'm today i'm joined
uh with uh i'm pleased to be joined with
my co-moderator
robert bezell who's an urgent professor
in the department of
molecular cellular and development
biology and before his arrival to yale
in 2013 he
served for 38 years as
chief science and health correspondent
for nbc news
so bob welcome as a reminder
all attendees have their volume and
video muted but we are eager to
incorporate your questions
you can simply submit those using the q
a feature in zoom
we are also streaming this session on
facebook
because uh due to dr fauci's popularity
and the topic he's covering we exceeded
our zoom license
fairly early on so we as facebook is our
spillover i think it's a testament not
just to dr fauci's gravitas
but also the importance of science in
this
unique moment in our time
so now let me introduce very quickly
uh our distinguished guest dr tony fauci
he's the director of naid the national
institute for of
for allergy and infectious diseases at
nih
uh where he's an exemplar for
an administrator scientist he is one of
the most productive
biomedical scientists um in in you know
alive
uh of our time and has contributed
substantially not just to the science uh
but also to policy
uh he was instrumental in some of the
most successful
public health initiatives um including
uh
helping design pepfar among other things
uh welcome dr fauci um formally to our
uh conversation series um and um
we it would be great if you could
provide an update
on the current situation with covet 19
including
where we are in the development of
therapeutics and vaccines
and a very brief update and then we'll
start with our
uh formal questions thank you very much
uh dr omar thank you for having me it's
a pleasure to be here
um so i wish i had a more
um positive report on where we
are right now but unfortunately the
reality
is right in front of us we're in a very
difficult position regarding
the uh dynamics of the outbreak in the
united states as you well know
we've had a very rocky course with a a
real
bad northeastern part of the country
dominated predominantly by the new york
metropolitan area which
overlapped a bit into connecticut where
about
40 of all the infections in the country
uh were dominated coming out of the new
york metropolitan area
when that cooled down a bit we saw the
rest of the country start to catch fire
and one of the things that's important
is that when we had
a blast of of patients
and then it would come down we never got
to a baseline
lower than twenty thousand and then when
we got down there we decided
as a nation we were going to try and
open up the economy
with some proposals for some i believe
very reasonable guidelines
for gateway and phase one phase two
phase three
however the various states throughout
the country
adhered in a very variable and disparate
way to the guidelines
leading to a surge of cases dominated by
the southern states
florida georgia texas arizona southern
california
so that we had a surge of cases that
went up to about
70 000 per day and then came back down
to around 40 and was stuck
at 40 for about a month and then how
much to our dismay
with the colder weather coming in the
cooler months of the fall and soon the
colder months
of the winter we're seeing over the last
couple of days the highest
per day number of cases that we've seen
in the entire outbreak
83 000 over the weekend
this is a very precarious position to be
in
as we go to the cooler months with more
indoor
activities versus outdoors and the
upcoming holiday
season superimposed upon that
is the issue that when you look at the
map of the country
and you look at the uptick in test
positivity
it is really diffused with about you
know 30k
30 states or more having upticks in
cases which means
the daily cases are going to be even
higher than they are now
and as i said a moment ago and i
repeated that is disturbing to me is
that i was hoping
that we could use the summer months to
get a grip
more on the outbreak so that when we
enter into the cooler months
we'll be well positioned we're not well
positioned so unfortunately
that's a sobering news summary however
on the other side of the coin
is that things are looking quite
positive in the arena of vaccines as
many know it's been broadly
advertised that there are six candidates
that the united states government
is very very strongly supporting either
from a developmental
or an implemental standpoint regarding
clinical trials
two of these right now started phase
three
in july 27 and three others
soon thereafter so we have five
candidates
in phase three trials the ones moderna
and fisa that started in july 27
are now virtually fully enrolled and we
should start
seeing data from the standpoint of
number
of infections in either the placebo or
the vaccine on
very soon so that we predict that by the
end of november
the beginning of december we will know
whether we have a safe and effective
vaccine and i'd be happy to discuss that
during the chat but i feel cautiously
optimistic that we will have
safe and effective vaccines that will
come to roll out by the end of the year
the beginning
of this coming year finally in therapy
you know we have good reasonable good
therapy for advanced disease
for example the dexamethasone study from
the uk clearly showed
a big survival benefit for people on
ventilators or requiring high flow
oxygen
rem desevere showed an increase or a
decrease in the time
to discharge from the hospital and
currently there are a number of trials
now
where things like convalescent serum
immune globulin
and importantly monoclonal antibodies
which everyone is paying a lot of
attention
to i would say in one final note we need
to do better
in getting more therapies for early
infection in other words to keep people
out of the hospital as opposed to
mitigating their course
once they are in the hospital so the
direction that's going to be pursued
very aggressively in the next few months
is looking at what we can do early on
as a treatment in the course of
infection so i'll stop there and i'd be
happy to answer any questions again in
any discussions
good so i'll start with the first uh
question and then bob and i will
alternate and then we'll take audience
questions and
student questions um so the first
question is like
what could surprise us related to the
development of the covit 19 vaccines
what are we not actively thinking about
you have a ton of experience with
hiv vaccine developments of leading
and informing that program and many
others
is there something that we are not
thinking about
uh you know as a field well i wouldn't
say we're not
thinking about it dr omar i'm think i'm
saying that we
we hope it doesn't happen that is
there's no guarantee that vaccines are
going to be successful unless you
do and complete the clinical trial as
i've mentioned i'm cautiously optimistic
that we will be successful based on the
rather encouraging data from the animal
models as well as the phase
one data in these trials which induced
robust antibody responses to the level
equivalent to if not better than
convalescent plasma
the big open question is the durability
of the protection we know with
coronaviruses
that protection is not strikingly
durable
as we know from the recurrence of common
cold coronaviruses
repetitively year after year even with
the exact same molecular
virus you can get reinfected so that's
one of the concerns that we have
the other one that we want to hope we
don't see i don't think we will but
we've got to stay heads up for it
is enhancement caused by the vaccine
where you vaccinate someone
and you get a sub optimum response which
enhances
when the virus binds to the antibody you
get a difficult response i think we're
covering
the bases we have three separate
platforms
we have messenger rna platform we have a
variety of vectors
including adenovirus and vsv and we have
the standard tried intrude
recombinant protein with adjuvants so i
think april the base is covered i hope
we don't
have any negative surprises great
so um bob you want to take the next
question
[Music]
do you want to ask the next question but
uh you're on mute you're a mute bob
sorry about that good afternoon tony hi
bob nice to see you
hi good to see you too uh
everybody on this call might not know
that chris grady is your wife and a
prominent bioethicist and she recently
convened a panel
about what many people are thinking
might be a very
crucial question if a successful vaccine
comes along
which is would it be ethical to continue
the placebo groups
in the vaccines that are farther behind
in the pipeline
where does that issue stand now you know
it stands still
open for significant discussion bob but
one of the i think
core principles that were spelled out
and most people agreed
it really depends on what the level of
efficacy
is and what the availability
of vaccine for the general community is
if you only have
a couple of million doses that you're
not going to be able to distribute
so you wouldn't be depriving the people
in the trial
from the vaccine because they wouldn't
be getting it anyway and importantly
how effective is it if it's 98 effective
that's one thing if it's 70 75 effective
that's another
so if you have a moderately effective
vaccine and very few doses
most people feel for the good of society
it is best to keep the trial with a
placebo
arm in it only if you have a lot of
doses
and a very high efficacy would you then
might want to switch
to a uh breaking the blind
and then having the other studies do in
non-inferiority studies
which i don't think is going to happen
because the uh
verpac committee met and they were very
much in favor
of even if you get a mild signal in the
first
50 or so points of efficacy that you
continue the trial in an unblinded way
both for safety and for efficacy so
there's a good deal of sensitivity
about that in the positive way
so i'm glad you mentioned the wealthback
meeting that's for the audience this is
the
advisory committee independent advisory
committee to the fda
and it was i think it must have been the
most watched
uh meeting of pack it almost had the
thrill of a reality show
um there but with a lot more science um
and and so yeah so i'm glad you
mentioned that one question
that is coming from our audience
and i think that's the most frequently
asked question that i am asked and
anyone else
who has worked on infectious diseases as
and i'm sure you have i know that you've
been asked before
but um the most frequent question is
that
when can uh when do we think life will
get back to
normal and and the person who asked that
question put normal in quotes
um et cetera so would love for you to
sort of elaborate based on what you know
as of october 26 2020.
okay so you're right i get asked that
question
all the time and the answer is i don't
have a crystal ball to
say exactly when but i do have in my
mind
what would be maybe a little plan or a
road map
of how we're going to gradually approach
a degree of normality that might not be
normal as we knew it before december
of 2019 is that by the time you get
enough vaccine distributed throughout
the country
and that will depend really on a couple
of factors
of what the uptake of the vaccine is we
have a number of percentage right now
in the country who are very skeptical
about getting the vaccine
if we don't get good vaccine coverage
even if it's a
pretty uh effective vaccine it's not
going to have the effect that we need
namely decreasing
the incidence of infection in the
country to such a low level
that people could start doing things as
what i call
approaching normal i want to make one
point
on where that is really important is
that i don't think for
quite a while at least a year that we're
going to be able to completely abandon
some of the public health measures that
we're doing now such as
wearing of mass keeping distance
avoiding congregate settings
to get a good vaccine and the incidence
and prevalence goes
way down then you could start gradually
marching into things that are more
normal what do i mean by that
restaurants that are at maybe close to
build capacities finally
opening up theaters and opening up
uh venues of entertainment that people
can go to but to say that once you get a
vaccine
we're going to be free to do whatever we
want that just is not going to happen
i would imagine at least through 2021.
so i guess that in that time you'll be
able to go to a nationals game
and i'll be able to go to an orioles
game one of us is likely to be more
disappointed than the other but um
so so bob um um your question
yeah one of the things tony is that
in this as you well know you've become
one of the best-known people in america
and
probably the world and as a symbol of
science
versus political pressure how long
if at all this is another crystal ball
question would take
to untangle that what many see as a
battle
between science and politics
that's a great question bob it's not
going to happen overnight
whether or not you have a change of
administration it's not going to just
go away i think it's something that we
need to deal with regardless of
how the election goes because there is a
core feeling
among some people uh of an anti-science
um anti-authority uh
pushback on what people feel
is being imposed upon them by
individuals who think they know more
than them
and i think that that's something that
as a nation we really need to grapple
and people are now writing
essays and books upon about that about
how we have such a divisiveness
in society and in fact the divisiveness
includes
a divisiveness about what the role of
science is
and what the role of truth and
investigation and data
and then we we're dealing with things
right now that are so disturbing
conspiracy theories things that have
absolutely no foundation
in reality it's so antithetical to what
the scientific process is
that we've got to deal with it it's here
and it's not going to go away
in a month or two or three i think we
have to start dealing with
um understanding why
there are segments in society that are
so anti-science
and try and engage them as opposed to
staying so separate and um
almost like an enemy of
of each other it should not be that way
obviously i mean i
i know you as a scientist and all of us
as scientists are very disturbed at that
but we really got to reach out and see
if we can mitigate that a bit
can i just ask a quick follow-up on that
uh
this is you're talking to what would be
defined as an elite
this is a university and scientists who
for the most part agree that the science
should be followed
i know you've been enormously busy but
have you thought about what specific
things we can do
to try to change that perception and
that
uh you know it's such a challenge as you
point out
you know i i'm not so sure i can give
you the one two three things that we
should do but i do
think that we cannot continue to be
at odds with the other group the people
who feel that we
are elite and feel that we are looking
down at them
that is i think the core reason why we
have the divisiveness
right now like people want to poke a
stick in the eye of the elite because
the elite
have in many respects disrespected them
we have to figure out how we can get rid
of that disrespect
and get some sort of harmony in the
country it's very very
disturbing to see the intensity
of the divide the divisiveness and bob i
mean it's no secret now because it's
been
all over the newspapers how it as you
said that i become the symbol
of science and rationality and clarity
but that has created as many admirers
as there are people who are actually
threatening
me i mean seriously threatening
me it isn't like i don't like you it's
like
i have outside the door about 20 feet
from how
federal agents that are guarding me i
mean that's ridiculous
i mean how preposterous does that in
2020 to have that that's to me
mind-boggling yeah so when we think of
global health security we never think of
actual security people
we think of other kinds of things so
staying on that topic
i i i'm sure i don't think you ever
thought that you
yourself will be part of an intervention
uh that someone would evaluate and we
did exactly that
staying on this topic so partnering with
our colleagues
in across uh campus at yale college our
political science colleagues
we did ran a series of experiments um
survey experiments where we randomized
people
into giving them hypothetical scenarios
where we said
that when would the vaccine you know you
know if the vaccine was approved
a week before the election which is
today
uh versus in december and we said uh
independently what would be their
acceptance of the vaccine and not
surprisingly
there was irrespective of political
affiliation although there were certain
differences
uh the acceptance of the vaccine was
higher if it were approved or authorized
in december but in another experiment we
found that whose endorsement would make
people take the vaccine
and not surprisingly your endorsement
and that's why you were part of our
intervention
was uh the highest
inspired the highest level of confidence
but the other sign was
that if for example the president and
the speaker of the house
endorsed it together that would also
have a positive substantial positive
effect
but your impact exceeded even the joint
endorsement and so so so just to set up
the so this setup was to ask you
that how any lessons
for future science communicators
uh that that to earn this level of trust
that you have earned in the middle of a
pandemic
and it's not it hasn't come since you
know your appearance
from january because you had a cache for
of several decades
um and the reason i'm specifically
asking this question because i've always
said that universities
have a unique role universities outlast
corporations they outlast
institutions and often as oxford and
cambridge
uh they outlast uh republics or
political systems
and so it is their unique responsibility
to transfer that knowledge so in that
spirit no pressure dr fauci uh
what is the lesson for future scientific
communicators
uh to build and accumulate that level of
trust that you have accumulated
um that's that's that's quite a question
but um i can just give you a couple of
principles that i
um have abided by over the decades that
i've been
doing this one is consistency
based on the data
admit when you do not know something i
mean
scientists who try to guess that's bad
anybody can guess as well as anybody
else
always go by the data and the scientific
evidence and information and when you're
when you're communicating
i think this may be one of the most
important things
is that when you're trying to
communicate science the goal
is not to show everybody how smart you
are
the goal is to get people to understand
what you're talking about
so often scientists and i don't mean
this in a pejorative
way they don't do it maliciously or even
in an ego way
but when they're trying to explain
something they have this little
bird inside them that tells them i
really gotta look good
you know you don't really have to look
good you just need to be understood
and when people don't understand you
they then throw up their arms about
science and they say these people don't
have any idea what they're talking about
so forget about it so be consistent know
when you don't know something don't be
afraid to say
i don't know and try to be understood as
opposed to looking smart
tony you just created a bumper sticker
don't try to look good
be understood i think that if
nothing else comes out of this
conference i think that would be a very
good one
uh i i and i i just want to add quickly
here that
i've i've known dr fauci for a long time
and another definition of my career was
he interviewed dr fausti because i
probably
how many times have i interviewed you
but he when he didn't
he was thrust into this position but he
handled it the way he did not by
accident
it took decades of enormously hard work
staying in the laboratory every day
visiting the clinic every day
and i i on behalf of everybody here and
i think a lot of people in america
i want to thank you for that and i want
to ask you a
question though i did want to lead to a
question which is
when you take something like the great
barrington uh declaration
uh about herd immunity and
people put it out who have mds and phds
after their names
and there's people on the other side who
trash it who have mds and phds after
their names
how do you deal with that when there is
a
dispute in the scientific community it's
not like
peter duisberg versus the hiv deniers
not one person against the world it's a
group of people against a
maybe a larger group of people but how
do you explain the facts
in a way that you get across the message
you want to get across
you know i i think what it is bob is a
little bit of
of what i was saying about about being
understood
instead of attacking people who have
an opposite opinion and blowing them off
and insulting them
what you need to do is to try and
articulate to the general
public why you feel
that what is implied in that declaration
doesn't make sense from a scientific
standpoint based on data
that we already have and let me just
give you an example
i noted that there are a lot of people
who signed the declaration and i think
one
one of the misleading aspects of that is
the declaration
in and of itself doesn't say but it
implies this issue of hurt immunity and
what you need to do to get hurt immunity
the two main tenets of the declaration
are a that we need to protect
the vulnerable that's for sure we want
to protect the vulnerable
there's no doubt about that and in
protecting the vulnerable
that we need to make sure that
we have a situation where we don't
shut down the government so i can say
i agree a hundred percent with both of
those tenants
we don't want to shut not the government
the country we don't want to lock down
the country
indefinitely because that'll destroy the
economy
and the so-called cure is worse than the
disease
and two we want to protect the
vulnerable however
implied in that is if you let everyone
get infected
and protect the vulnerable the people in
the nursing homes
the people in prisons and people like
that everything will be all right
the one fact that's missing in that
is that 30 to 40 percent of the general
population
are vulnerable so if you're gonna let
the infection
just read to let everyone get so-called
immunity in order to get
60 75 of the people
infected there are going to be several
hundreds of
thousands of more deaths that is not
maybe that is a fact so
if you can get people to understand that
that yes
we feel we want to protect the
vulnerable and
no we don't want to shut down the
economy
but that doesn't mean that this idea of
letting everybody gets infected don't do
anything to prevent infection
is a good thing and i think you just
need to explain it in those terms
as opposed to saying you're crazy you
don't know what you're talking about
just talk about the facts that's all
so so building on upon that uh so when
whenever we
we have faced large public health
problems
like the impact of tobacco like hiv
testing
it has been paired with um a public
health communications campaign or series
of campaigns
and for those of us who follow these
kinds of things
um yes there has been messaging
at the highest level you have played a
huge role but we have we are not seeing
a conventional public health campaign
around covet 19. for example working
with the ad council cdc
working with the ad council and having
specific goals outlined in terms of
um you know acceptance of behavior etc
and so on and so forth
um going forward um there is
uh there are signs of um
of emerging vaccine hesitancy some of it
is
you know frankly not irrational in the
sense
that you know looking at expecting a
mainstream
unpolitical non-political approval
process
but on top of that sits the conventional
vaccine hesitancy
that focuses on the conventional drivers
if you will
of vaccine hesitancy what is what do you
think and the national academies also
recommended a national communications
campaign
around covet 19 vaccines any thoughts of
a large-scale appropriately resourced
um national campaign and who does it
and and any features as a frontline
communicator
of of science in this pandemic any
thoughts on that kind of a
large scale campaign and that's an
amalgamation of a lot of questions that
we have been getting from the audience
yeah i mean that is actually uh in play
to a certain extent
and will even get larger than that and
that is
fundamentally from the cdc with the
department of health and human services
being the main
player of that and that really is
community
engagement at a level very similar
to what we did with hiv back when we
were doing the clinical trials
of prevention and therapy that we wanted
to get
the the constituency who had skepticism
about the federal government getting
involved in clinical trials and
developing what's called
community liaisons and community
outreach that's already being done right
now i'm
actually taking part of that in some
psas and some more
broad approaches to that i think we
probably need to do it a little bit more
intensively
but it is already on its way to being
started
so i will add a supplemental questions
which is in the sort of the behavioral
communication system which which is from
a six-year-old
from a yale a child of a
yale community member and and the the
child asks
why can't we have more mass breaks at
school and that points to a sort of a
more
uh you know specific but a broader
strategy of
you know ensuring compliance from the
youngest members of our society
he said mask breaks yeah mass breaks and
that's a question from a six-year-old
namely when you can take your mask off
exactly
well that's interesting that really
tells you the stress that goes down to
the level of a six-year-old
about even though masks appear to be
easy to do i mean it just is a bother
keeping a mask on all the time um
you know i do when i'm outside but i
spend most of my time in here and
there's nobody around but me so i don't
have it on but it would be something but
you know
um it is worthwhile uh
bringing up the point that i always say
that this is not going to last
forever and when people feel there's no
end in sight
keeping a mask on or keeping a distance
or staying out of crowds
becomes all the more burdensome however
if one sees the light at the end of the
tunnel
you can say i could stick this out a
little bit longer so maybe that's one of
the messages
we can tell the six-year-old hang in
there
you're not gonna wear it forever i
promise you yeah
and if there's any consolation a lot of
adults are acting like six-year-old
names should not remain unmentioned um
and so bob yeah one of the questions
tony you were talking before about the
the cdc and its role and i know there's
been discussion about that and i'm not
going to ask you
about the specifics now but in going
forward
do you think it would be a good idea if
the cdc
gave out more of the grant money for
public health
uh the nih gives a lot of it now and as
a result of that the nih has a lot of
constituents in many states because it
goes to many states and
uh that as you well know uh helps you
with congress
uh the cdc gives out grants to state and
local health departments but it's a
small fraction of what
the nih gives out as grants would it be
more helpful if more money flowed
from the cdc to get them a better
constituency in the country
yeah i think that's a very good point
bob you know the cdc
even though they've been somewhat
lessened and somewhat in line during
this covet outbreak is still an
outstanding public health organization
and i think if they did
connect a bit more outside with the
public health
people particularly in the academic
public health
like the schools of public health and
places like that i think that would be
not only
to their benefit but to the benefit of
the country
i agree with you so uh another question
uh that crystallizes you know you know
several questions that are coming from
our audiences but i'll frame it slightly
differently
so this country started taking pandemic
preparedness a little bit more seriously
after anthrax especially after the h5n1
scare
um and there were a lot of things that
were done and you were at the forefront
of a lot of
those effort but even if you were not
directly involved you were engaged in
the broader process
things like platform technologies and
all of that so that has continued
uh since then what did we do right
um that is because a lot of discussion
has been
what we are doing wrong but there are a
lot of things we did right
um what did we do right in
since let's say 2005 2006
that is paying dividends now well i
think one of the things we did
right uh dr omar is what you just
mentioned
we we said in order to prepare
for pandemics we need to do two major
buckets
one is to improve our public health
capability be that at the local level or
the international uh
global health security agenda and global
health security network
we did that right that's one of the
things we did right
but something we did even more right was
to focus
on things like platform technologies and
prototype
pathogens where you actually and i think
our ability to move from the sequence of
the
coronavirus on january the 9th
to a phase one trial 65 days later
to a phase three trial six months later
is beyond incredible it is
it's historic in being able to do that
and that was all technological advances
in concentrating on platform
technologies
that's what we discussed back when you
said we were worrying about h5n1
and post anthrax we made a decision
we were going to build our public health
capacity but we were also going to focus
on doing things in the scientific arena
that would better position us the other
thing that i just want to mention
is that we've been pursuing is called
the prototype
pathogen approach in other words if you
look at flaviviruses
you know all of the things we've done
with flaviviruses successful vaccines
with yellow fever
you know japanese encephalitis and then
all of a sudden west nile comes along i
mean it's really
very interesting how you could learn
we're going to be doing the same thing
right now
with coronaviruses we've had three
pandemics with coronaviruses
nothing until 2002
with sars then mares and now kovid
you know if we don't develop a universe
a coronavirus vaccine shame on us
no i think that i think that's a that's
a really good point what
one of the things in public health
communication
that is can be very difficult is you
have to
talk about certain populations such as
incarcerated people who are at
high risk both to themselves and
to the community members because of the
staff and the institutions that take
care of them
and then go home to their families how
do you convince people that it's a hey
it's a really good idea to maybe
consider shortening the sentences of
people who
are in prison and may end up with a
death sentence
because of this virus when that might
not not be so politically popular
well that's something that we feel
strongly about and i've spoken about
that
right at the very beginning uh when we
see when we were seeing these
major outbreaks in nursing homes and
prisons
is that you really want to take a look
at the population and say
is this really worth the risk to this
person
who's in for a non-violent crime who's
done things like
you know smoke marijuana or whatever it
was that they put them in there
it's you know i think we really do need
to look at that it's something that's
not in my area of expertise so i don't
want to
opine too strongly on it but it's
certainly something that was brought up
in our discussions when we knew that
there were outbreaks in prisons
so um you know a pandemic is just that
it's a pandemic it's
it's it's global uh et cetera and if
anything that has
um shown us the importance of frankly
global engagement it is this pandemic um
and so
moving forward and we are an institute
for global health
uh you know yale institute for global
health which is hosting this event and
we think about this all the time
moving forward irrespective of sort of
what has happened in the five
six seven eight months uh with the u.s
engagement with the world and who
how should our you know how should we
broadly engage
uh global health institutions around the
world to address this
pandemic because it is not going away
tomorrow
and future pandemics well i think we
need to
intensify by several fold our engagement
globally
uh with the global health community
because as you well know from your own
position that there are very competent
global health
institutions in different countries not
only
in the uk and in europe but also in asia
and some in south america all of which
we've dealt with i think we need
to very much strengthen our interactions
and collaborations
with them because that can do nothing
but make our job much
easier for the next outbreak which
absolutely is going to come you know we
keep talking about this
is that it's not a matter of when if
it's a matter of when and
unfortunately we're right now in the
middle
of what's going to be referred to i
think historically you know as the
mother
of all outbreaks over the last hundred
years um
and we're not even close to being
finished with it yet
so to get back to a specific uh about
treatments monoclonals looked very good
in two patients that have been
publicized the governor of
new jersey and the president of the
united states but monoclonal antibodies
are not
molecular molecules that can be made
very cheaply they have to be made in
vats as you well know what what is the
chance for significant production of
that form of
treatment uh to an extent that it might
be useful because it
there are indications that given early
it's it could be very useful
is it ever going to be cost effective
and
able to be produced widely enough to
meet the needs
yeah bob i would be disappointed if we
can't get over that hurdle
i mean technically we can figure out a
way to mass produce them i mean
we've done much more complicated things
than that you're absolutely correct
the way things stand now you're talking
about the availability of
hundreds of thousands of doses and not
tens of millions of doses i believe we
can get to that
and just a comment about monoclonal
antibodies
i think people should be aware that from
the standpoint of a mechanistic
approach to the therapeutic efficacy of
monoclonal antibodies you really want to
give it very early
in the course of infection because
we know from experience now with covert
19
that the virus is very important in the
very early days
but you know after a period of time
measured in several days to weeks
it's the aberrant inflammatory response
that gets people into trouble because
if you try and even get virus isolated
from people
after a week or 10 days it's sometimes
very difficult to do
so if you're gonna hit the virus with a
monoclonal antibody
you better do it within the first couple
of days which means
you have to have it widely available for
people to get
in an outpatient setting
great um so in terms of you know there's
a couple of questions coming
uh from the perspective of when do you
think
um we will know or uh
we will get reach quote-unquote herd
immunity
or i think the you know the herd
immunity threshold would it be
homogeneous would it be heterogeneous
and similarly
in terms of looking at if you look at
the immune landscape at the population
level
are there any things
[Music]
we should be concerned about in terms of
enhanced disease that you alluded to
in the context of sort of vaccine trials
but um but in terms of infection
versus and and on top of that a mass
vaccination
program so so anything that we need to
um to think about as scientists and any
questions uh research questions that
help
answer and and hopefully mitigate the
possibility of enhanced disease
antibod body mediated or otherwise all
right so you have a couple of really
good questions and they're all
together so let me so let me go through
them first of all
you know obviously enhanced disease is
um
always something hanging over you as a
possibility
there have been some recent experiments
done with
non-neutralizing antibodies against
places
other than the receptor binding domain
of the spike protein
and they have shown in in some really
interesting unpublished data
and not to have any enhancement at all
so even though i think we always
need to worry about enhancement i do
think it's much less of an issue
than people are making of it that
doesn't mean we're going to discard it
but i don't think that's going to be a
showstopper
for us at all your question about herd
immunity
you know we can guess what the
percentage of people
who are immune to give so-called hurt
immunity
i don't know what it is i say you know
70 75
80 percent of the people as a good guest
it's not 20
it's not it's not going to be 20 so how
do you get to hurt immunity
well you get to hurt immunity by getting
people immune one of two ways they
either get infected
they get vaccinated or a combination of
both
if we're relying on infection alone the
disease and
death burden to get you to get 70
percent of the population
is unacceptable completely so it's going
to have to be
a vaccine that's at least modestly
effective and i say modestly i mean 77
or 5 percent
i'd love a 90 but i'm not sure we're
going to get
there with wide uptake of the vaccine
which gets back
to our conversation a little while ago
about getting people who were reluctant
to get vaccinated vaccinated
and finally buried in there a source of
anxiety
for me is what is the durability of the
protection
so herd immunity is great as long as
you're immune
we may need to come back with boosters
if the durability of the protection is
not very good
yeah i think those of us who work on
vaccines related questions
are looking at an employment security
kind of a scenario
for the next few years and i say that in
jest but but you know
there are a lot of questions interesting
questions uh that will not only inform
this uh pandemic's response but
vaccinology
more broadly if i may go to sort of um
another question and then we'll ask
uh bob to um sort of add any other
questions
so looking at you your role
as a major scientific leader would love
to hear
how does niaid and how does nih
change and and the broader scientific
enterprise
change after this pandemic what do we do
different going forward um
and so i don't know if you have thought
about it or or if you have any
perspectives on that
well i think what this out
i mean i i don't want to speak for nih
as a whole
except for one aspect of it but
particularly with regard to infectious
diseases
and outbreaks i think what what
we learned from this outbreak what niaid
might change
is just not necessarily change but
underscore
the reality that outbreaks have always
occurred
they are occurring now when they will
continue to occur
so even though you need to make an
investment in established
infectious diseases like tuberculosis
and malaria
and hiv which not too long ago was an
emerging infectious disease now it's
a you know almost a 40-year established
infectious disease so we've learned that
the other thing that we've learned is
how quickly you can turn on a dime and
it may change that which is the
importance
of being able to supplement grants
quickly
and get investigators who are not
involved in something involved in it
it's amazing how both intramurally and
extramurally
we have people in my own lab who've been
doing hiv
for the last 25 years are now
looking at glycosylation of spiked
proteins
on kobe so it's it's really very
interesting how people can
quickly change on a dime and do their
and do
really important things in an area that
they weren't expert in
yeah no so it's been fascinating to see
mostly positive that people have
switched from
you know hiv research influenza in
certain cases radiology
uh neuroradiology specifically to being
infectious disease experts most of it is
good
i think i can say that confidently
exceptions apply um
so bob i'll give you the last questions
and then i'd be
happy to wrap up okay well here's
one last question tony you have answered
an astounding amount of questions
in the last weeks and months uh beyond
beyond belief uh is there anything you
wish you had been asked that you haven't
been asked
is there anything i wish
you know i don't think i think i have
actually bob been asked
virtually every possible
question i cannot think of something
that i would have said gee
this is silly why didn't they ask this
question and i
think the reason for that bob is that
this
we're really living i mean i think right
now we almost don't realize it but when
this is over
which it will end i keep telling people
that particularly younger people who
seem frustrated but
that's going to go on this will end when
we look back at this
this is really going to be a of an
incredibly historic
experience that we've all been through
and
and i hope there are going to be some
important
lessons that we learn from this about
what we've done right what we haven't
done
right but i think in answer to your
question i think i've been asked
virtually every imaginable question many
more times than once
and just very quickly said and i'll get
to give it back to you for to conclude
but from the volume of
and questions have been submitted by the
audience
i think nothing sparked more uh palpable
reaction than your use of the year 2022
uh in thinking about a possible end to
this how do you reassure
people to keep going to keep up and have
faith
well i i think it's going to be because
it's going to get better and better
gradually it's not going to be
horrible until the end of 2021
once we get the vaccine mobilized once
we get that baseline
level of infection down and get people
to fully appreciate and realize
that you've got to do some fundamental
public health things to keep this
infection rate down
i think people are going to start to see
you know kind of like
the sun coming up a little bit of light
a little bit more a little bit
all of a sudden there's a bright sun
there and hey we're out of it
i think that's what's going to happen i
think that's what's going to happen
great so thank you for um an
enlightening
conversation today and and i know that
you know the excitement of your family
being excited about
you being on tv goes away after the
first four appearances
for you the point was crossed in in the
1980s probably
after that it becomes abstraction for a
working scientist to go out and
communicate again and again
with people with varying level of
receptivity be it expert audiences
or academic settings or the general
public uh
but this is important and thanks for
recognizing that
thanks for continuing to be productive
as a scientist
um and uh being a communicator so so uh
you have uh set a high benchmark uh for
everyone else so
uh you know people would get their um
tenures they'll become
their national academies uh sort of uh
membership then there will always be the
bar to appear on a cupcake
that will be hard to meet so so thanks
for setting that bar
um for the community and being an
example
uh and i appreciate you being here and
for the audience uh just to remind
everyone this
the next one uh of this series on
november 11th
uh with uh henrietta four uh who's the
executive director of unicef
uh where we learn more about their
trailblazing work in childhood
um child health both broadly and in the
context of covet 19 because
children have been disproportionately
impacted not
by the disease as much also by the
disease as well
but the pandemic as a broader social
concept
by perhaps uh you know they're one of
the top most effective groups
in terms of development and education
etc so stay tuned
we'll see you on the november 11th and
thanks again bob for co-moderating and
dr fauci
for taking time to be here thank you
very much dr omar i appreciate you
having me and bob
it's always great to see you my friend
take care indeed